- Hi, I'm Ari and I got a
hundred people at my work
to stop sucking for a week
and it made me think about
how I could get more
people to stop sucking.
This is a story about how
I went my state's capitol,
Sacramento, to try to
help get Californians to
stop using single use plastic straws.
But wait, why?
- [Person] Aww man!
- [Ari] 500 million
plastic straws are used
in the U.S. every day many
of those straws end up
in the ocean and can harm sea life.
Reports predict that by 2050 there will be
more plastic I the ocean than fish.
My journey starts with Shelia Morovati.
She's a mom in L.A. who's
instrumental in getting
the city of Malibu to ban straws.
- We found this many
straws just walking for
five minutes at the beach.
So I went to the city and I asked if they
would implement the ban,
and not only did they vote
on it unanimously,
banning all plastic straws
but also plastic cutlery and stirrers.
- That's amazing
- It was awesome.
- After talking to Shelia I
was so inspired and I wanted
to see how I could get
involved to address the problem
of single use plastic straws.
So I decided to do some research.
I discovered that Ian Calderon,
the California State assembly leader,
had created a bill called
Straws Upon Request.
I called his office to ask if
he would tell me more about it
and he agreed to meet with me.
- It's a really easy,
simple bill, it just says
you go into a full service,
dine-in restaurant,
you want a straw, you can have it,
you just have to request it.
So, straws upon request.
We're not banning it, but
we are raising awareness,
and I think it's gonna cut down
on the prevalence of straws.
- How do you think
people can get involved?
- The best type of advocacy is always
to reach out to your elected officials.
So you have assembly member
Laura Friedman, who is amazing
- Okay. Okay, great.
- And your State Senator is Kevin De Leon.
It depends on what
you're willing to do, so,
you can go into your
assembly member's office,
- Mm hmm
- You can even write your
assembly member a letter,
or you can call in.
- Okay.
- That's what you can do locally.
- Yeah.
- The next thing is you've
got to fly to Sacramento.
- Oh.
- I'd love to have you
there, it's really cool.
- Oh 100%.
- About to get on the plane to Sacramento
(pilot on intercom)
- I just arrived, I feel
like I'm on Parks and Rec.
So I'm a little nervous
can you give me any advice?
- [Shelia] Go out there, be positive,
and make your case known.
- Thank you so much Shelia.
We're going to be presenting the bill
at the natural resources
committee, and if it passes,
it will move along to
the California Senate.
She's gonna be a witness
and I'm gonna testify.
Are you nervous?
- I mean, not really, cuz it's something
that needs to be done, so,
it's just, just gotta do it.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Alright welcome everyone, to
start us off is Mr. Calderon
- And the reason why I'm doing this bill,
is because we have an issue
with single use plastics
- I learned about the problem
that plastic pollution
poses to our ocean as a volunteer
teen conservation leader
at the Monterey Bay Aquarium,
and decided to take action for my
Girl Scout Gold Award project.
I founded Jr. Ocean Guardians,
an organization dedicated
to educating people about the
problem of plastic pollution
I urge each and every one
of you to vote in favor of
this congressman's legislation.
- Any further witnesses in support
of this bill please come forward.
- Hi, my name is Ari Jackson
and I'm here, to testify
in support of this bill and
also to show that there is
strong public support for it.
I'm a video producer at Buzz
Feed and I made a video about
why straws are harmful to our environment.
This video was viewed on
Facebook 20 million times
and it got 194,000 shares.
The top audience for this video
was Californians ages 25 to 34.
The public, is,
very excited about this bill,
and I urge you to protect
the health of our oceans in California.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- [Ari] So how do you think it went.
- It went as expected, and, you know,
- Yeah
- I'm feeling confident
about the overall solution of the bill.
- Yeah. I was nervous
but I think it went well.
- No, you did a really good job
- Okay, I stumbled a
little bit, I was like,
up there I was like oh no!
- It's totally normal.
I mean cuz it's funny, like,
right when you get up there,
you know exactly what you're
going to say when you're going, right?
- Yeah.
- And then you get
there and it's just like
- And like in the middle,
yeah I got a little fumble,
but, you guys all did great.
Yay, thank you!
- Of course.
- The Straws Upon Request
bill passed through
the assembly floor and
it is currently waiting
to be approved on the
California Senate floor.
If you want to see it pass,
and reach Governor Brown's desk
call your representatives
to tell them you support it.
Curbing single use straw
use is a great start,
but they are just one facet of
our single use plastic problem.
I believe one person can
make a difference, and
if you do to please sign our pledge below
to not use plastic straws anymore.
- You know I still get tweets
all the time talking about
how I suck because I'm
going to put people in jail.
Even though it's not even in the bill.
The penalty's were not
what I put in the bill,
they were prescribed in my
bill due to the code section.
- Yeah.
- But that's okay, because it's part
of the legislative process.
I know that, and I know
ultimately, what the end result is,
and it's all worth it.